over the weekend bitcoin's price crashed
aggressively and there was a Cascade of
liquidations across the market now a lot
of people are wondering why is Bitcoin
crashing given the global macro
environment wasn't Bitcoin supposed to
be an inflation hedge what exactly is
happening in these portfolios but
there's a key thing to remember yes
bitcoin's correlation to other assets
including the S P 500 hitting an
all-time high right now Bitcoin and the
S P 500 a correlation of 0.6 now of
course up until 2020 there was no
correlation at all between Bitcoin and
other assets it was a non-correlated
asset but once the institution started
to come in and they started to adopt
Bitcoin and put it in their portfolio
now all of a sudden they treat Bitcoin
as the most risky asset in their
portfolio if the global macro
environment calls for risk off well
guess what the institutions do they sell
those assets they go back to value
stocks or some sort of commodity in
which they feel is less risky now of
course the Institute tuitions act
completely differently than the retail
investors who are simply dollar cost
averaging into Bitcoin they continue to
accumulate more regardless of price but
we can go all the way back to 2008 and
2009 to get a little bit of History to
understand how correlations and
liquidity crisis play out here you can
see the gold price chart back in 2007
2008 and 2009. you can see that over the
summer of 2008 gold went down 30 percent
that liquidity crisis of the 2008 Global
financial crisis meant that all asset
correlations trended towards one even
though many people would accept the fact
that gold served as a safe haven or an
inflation hedge asset it still was not
immune to the liquidity crisis that was
at play and so if you fast forward back
to 2022 we're in a liquidity crisis
right now it's not nearly as severe as
March of 2020 which was highly acute and
happened very quickly instead we've been
in a liquidity crisis since the end of
last year and now we're about eight
months into this and as the FED
continues to raise interest rates and
conduct quantitative tightening they
simply are forcing investors to sell any
asset that they can and raise cash the
US dollar is at a 20-year High
relatively compared to other Fiat
currencies but what you as an investor
need to understand is that liquidity
crisis they eventually go away and
correlations will return back to
something like where they were before
the liquidity crisis and so yes Bitcoin
and all other assets are going down
a global 60 40 portfolio filled with
stocks and bonds is down normally those
would have an inverse relationship
stocks go up bonds go down or vice versa
but that's not what we're seeing in this
current liquidity crisis that has lasted
more than six months all asset prices
are going down Bitcoin is not immune and
neither is any other asset class so
understanding how these types of assets
and liquidity crises interact is really
important Bitcoin and the S P 500
hitting an all-time high correlation
something tells me it won't stay here
over the long run but it's still
important to understand what's happening
today and try to figure out how you are
going to move your portfolio to be able
to protect yourself and or benefit on
the other side